taliban regained control of afghanistan
or were basically handed it back by
president biden in that time women's
rights have been dragged back to the
dark ages afghan girls have been banned
from full education women unable to earn
a living now for the first time in
decades all women are forced to wear the
islamic face fell the full burqa yet the
taliban still insists this is a measure
to ensure dignity and safety for their
sisters well joining me now for the
first time since these restrictions have
come into force is taliban official
spokesman suhail shaheen mr shaheen
thank you for joining me
thank you
you made a promise you rang into the bbc
on august the 15th 2021 and you said
this i want to remind you of what you
said
they should not be
scared their honor
their properties their right to
education work
is
we have commitment for that
so they should not have
worries their work
and
access to education
will be i think
more in a better position
than they were in the past
so that was you talking about women in
afghanistan and school girls and you
assured us that they would be in a
better position
than they were in the past but in fact
they've now gone back to the position
they were in when the taliban was in
charge before which is a position of
being oppressed
why is that and why did you lie about
improving a lot of women in afghanistan
your
first of all your
judgment is based on distorted reports
of media
right now
123
000
female students
and teachers
and government universities in private
universities
they are either working or receiving
education
do you know about that
you don't know i do know i do know
you ask
mentioned that in your program about
four million female students in primary
schools they are going to school yes
right now if you have pakistan all right
mr james let me jump in let me respond
to you let me respond to you please
don't just keep talking right it is true
that some primary school girls are still
going to school it's after they get to
teenage years it's it's after they get
to teenage years you have stopped them
going to school you don't want girls in
afghanistan to go through full-time
education that's not improving the
welfare and lifestyle of women in
afghanistan is suppressing them why
don't you let secondary school age girls
go back to school
the secondary age school primary school
there are four billion girls are going
to school now the issue of secondary
schools education for girls
they are uncom under consideration
we have never said they are banned
when you say that under consideration
what do you mean they're not currently
at school let them go back to school
just so you can all go back to school
that is why
we are uh talking
to work out a mechanism
a girl should be entitled to go to
school in afghanistan the same way a boy
goes to you yourself said in august last
year that they had nothing to worry
about nothing to be scared about so
they've got nothing to worry about let
them go back to school give them the
education that they were having give
them the education that they deserve
just do it stop telling them you're
under consideration
you've got to consider their right to
education
i said the girls have the right to have
access to education as boys i am saying
right now
that's why the the
mechanism in mechanisming being work out
to provide a conducive environment
because it is islamic society there is
no question about their right to to go
to school
only if there's some question again let
me jump in
let me respond to that
if i may respond to you and female
teachers if there is no problem about
their right to an education let them go
back to school let me turn if i may
to the issue of the now compulsory
instruction for all women in afghanistan
to wear a full burka if they go outside
in fact there's an encouragement they
don't leave their home but if they do
leave their home they can only show
their eyes and if they get caught
showing any more than their eyes then
the male guardians have been appointed
to basically enforce this
face going to prison
this is unbelievably oppressive way to
treat women in afghanistan after two
decades of experiencing a much freer
society why are you doing this when
again by your own words you promised
they had nothing to worry about
the upgrade women
for centuries
they have been observing
hijab
and they are
wearing hijab voluntarily
so there is no addition
borden on them and there there is
the statement doesn't say
is imposed or the only type of
it says there are different type
hijab which are acceptable all right so
this is important okay
what you're saying is true
so just to be clear just to be clear
every woman in afghanistan right now can
go out and does not have to wear the
full burqa and she will get no
bad treatment from taliban is that
correct they're all free not to wear the
burqa is that your official position yes
just
yeah yeah if they observe
uh hijab it may be a wheel it may be a
piece of cloth it may be a burka but it
is the burqa is not the only type of
hijab it is clearly said any type of a
piece of clothing
she covers herself her body that that is
our hijab so it is not the burka as you
said it's the decree the decree that
came down from the vice and virtue
ministry was that they were not allowed
to reveal more than their eyes so
whichever way you try and spin this
that is a draconian measure which is
designed to suppress women more than
they've been used to in the last two
decades you're taking them back to what
life was like under taliban before and
i'm simply putting it to you that when
you took over the country again last
august you made a lot of pronouncements
the taliban that you were going to be a
different kind of taliban a more
inclusive taliban and that women had
nothing again back to your words nothing
to be scared about their honor their
properties their right to education work
and so on
the kids after 12 13 can't go to school
all women have to wear a covering apart
from their eyes you know they're not
getting most jobs now apart from
women's specific jobs which can't be
filled by men they have men now
relatives and employers who are
exercising a control over them which can
be punishable if it's broken by
imprisonment this is incredibly
draconian i can't think of anywhere else
in the world that is doing this to women
and i just ask you again what part of
any of this
shows that you have changed the taliban
that you're more inclusive because i'm
not seeing any evidence that you're
doing anything other than taking women
right back to where they were 25 years
ago
what you are saying have gotten from
the media reports which are not correct
their property are safe secure
there's no problem with that
about
the the wheel it is not only in
afghanistan all over the islamic world
you may have it
in uk the muslim women are wearing also
in uk
about the only opening the eyes
you
many are using the mask there is no
problem it is the same as the mosque
you know yeah what's the problem now why
is that open so
if
the taliban will be judged by their
actions and the reports from reporters
in afghanistan are completely contrary
to the picture that you're trying to
paint they are talking about women who
are now protesting in the streets
because they're being ordered to
completely cover themselves apart from
their eyes they're being told that male
relatives and employers are now
enforcing this on behalf of the taliban
so either they're all making it up and
they've all gone mad or the taliban
through people like yourself as a
spokesman are saying one thing in public
and a very different thing is happening
on the streets i want to talk to you
also about the economy in afghanistan
which is a complete disaster you now
have millions and millions of people
living in abject poverty in what way is
the taliban trying to improve the lives
of its people because it seems from
where i'm looking that ever since the
united states evacuated uh afghanistan
things have got immeasurably worse for
the people
why is that why given a second chance at
running the country have you so far
proven to be such abject failures
first of all i would like to say
uh 99 percent of the upon women they are
observing hijab voluntarily
so
they consider it
a dignity
a safeguard for
their modesty modesty
secondly the poverty situation
uh the lack of job opportunity
opportunity is busy because of the
sanctions imposed
by international community uh following
our taking the capital of kabul
so they are
punishing
the people of afghanistan
not the government by imposing the
sanction you can ask them why they have
done this why they are doing this to the
people of afghanistan so your position
is that the taliban has no
responsibility for the economic collapse
of the country and it's all everybody we
have yeah yeah we have responsibility
what we have from our internal revenue
we are doing that
in this we are spending that in the
service of our people uh we are
starting
development projects we are paying the
salaries of
the government employees who are about
500 000 from the pure previous
government they are still working in the
government we are doing that but we have
do not have
okay financially so strong to store all
the uh development projects some of the
projects which were funded by um some
countries they have been all right
between 1990 personnel
the truth is afghanistan is in a
terrible state right now millions of
people are living in horrific poverty
women are feeling increasingly oppressed
by the taliban regime and my message to
you simply my message to you simply is
if we take you at face value then we
should
expect that tomorrow secondary age kids
can go back to school and get a proper
education and if you say there is no
order for women to wear the full
covering and they can go out without
covering everything apart from their
eyes let's see that happen and let's
make sure that women that do express
that right and that freedom do not then
get punished we're going to leave it
there mr shaheen thank you very much
indeed for joining me yes i i i i'm
saying right now that uh the women and
boys they have right to have access to
education that's only by observing hijab
yeah you don't have any right to
education if there's no school you can
go to our appointment
has not said that that denied that
they're like
we've talked about
that
we've talked about this just for the
record you have two daughters do they go
to school
yeah of course yeah yes
of course they do because you're in and
they can go to school right
they are observing hijab they are
observing any hijab and so well that
means we have not denied so they behave
to our people so they do exactly
if your daughters do exactly what you
tell them they're allowed to get okay so
your daughter's getting education
because
wait a minute
your daughter's your daughter's getting
education because they do what you tell
them all right i'm glad we clarified
that uh sahil shaheen thank you very
much indeed for joining me well joining
me now is uh fanzia kufi she was one of
the first female politicians in
afghanistan until she fed the country
last year when the taliban took over you
were shaking your head in derision a lot
of the stuff that he was saying there
clearly a lot of that is propaganda we
know from the reporting on the ground
what is going on in relation to
education of young girls in relation to
women and what they have to wear what is
your response to that interview
well peers i only hope that
there was a debate that he could listen
to and my message to him would have been
mr shaheen you and i negotiated for the
past three years
we started from moscow in february
2019
i remember as the first woman to
negotiate with you it was extremely
risky because i lost a lot of support in
my constituents by talking to you but we
did it for the sake of the country
because we wanted to come to a peace
deal remember there
one of your uh uh just
i know you're doing it but he's gone
right i just wanna i mean so he can't
hear you so my point really is how much
of what he's saying is just propaganda
and nonsense from what you understand on
the ground i want to remind them because
i'm sure they will they will listen to
this that in that meeting one of their
negotiators say that from their
perspective woman could go to school
could go to university could work in
business in politics could become
minister minister of foreign affairs up
to prime minister none of that's
happening
i'm quoting up to prime minister it was
a room full of maine everybody looked at
me and said well miss goofy this is a
big news but in reality when they took
over power on the 15th of august the
first thing they did in contradiction
with islamic principles and what's
happening in the rest of muslim world
they stop girls from going to school
only girls up to grade 12 go to school
this is not happening in anywhere in the
world right anywhere they stop women
from going to work and you know what
these women actually were the bread
winners of their family they lost their
husbands in the war and they were the
supporters of their family they were
feeding their children with the money
that they were receiving through their
salary they cannot do it anymore because
they don't have a job to do it
now the last thing they did while the
country is at the age of starvation
economic crisis and people expect them
as people now in power to deliver the
last thing they did was another decree
asking women of afghanistan to wear
their favorite hijab which is burka now
let's remember that women of afghanistan
have always remained muslim and their
hijab the same way that i do is
acceptable in afghanistan by maine is
respected and this is part of our
identity we don't need taliban to come
and tell us that unless you don't wear
vel which is burka and it's even not
islamic it's traditional i think that's
something your male member of the family
will be punished so can you imagine in a
country which already the rule of law is
does not exist
the main are influencing and committing
violence well that's the right that's
the great irony is that the men are now
being told to enforce these rules by the
taliban and that in itself is just utter
misogyny
great to talk to you thank you very much
for coming in and just putting a woman's
perspective from afghanistan there i
think we all know what is happening on
the ground and it's completely
reprehensible the taliban are taking
these women back to a terrible time in
afghanistan's life and they've got to
stop it and the world needs to be
shining a light on this thank you very
much for coming